THE SUMMIT ON TUESDAY, ALSO
LOOKING BACK AT THIS WEEKEND'S
G-7 MEETING IN CANADA THAT ENDED
WITH A BIG BANG.
WE BEGIN RIGHT NOW WITH CHIEF
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT JOHN
ROBERTS WHO HAS BEEN TRAVELING
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
GOOD MORNING, JOHN.
>> BRET, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
WHAT WE'RE WITNESSING UNFOLD
HERE IN SINGAPORE COULD BE TRULY
HISTORIC.
WHAT HAPPENS HERE OVER THE NEXT
FEW DAYS COULD BEGIN THE PROCESS
TO ELIMINATE ONE OF THE GRAVEST
THREATS FACING THE WORLD, OR IT
COULD GO NOWHERE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOUCHED DOWN IN
SINGAPORE PRONOUNCING THAT HE IS
FEELING GOOD ABOUT THE PROSPECTS
OF HIS MEETING WITH KIM JONG-UN,
BUT AS HE DEPARTED THE G-7
SUMMIT IN QUEBEC, PRESIDENT
TRUMP ACKNOWLEDGED HE WAS FLYING
INTO THE UNKNOWN.
>> IT'S UNKNOWN TERRITORY IN THE
TRUEST SENSE.
BUT I REALLY FEEL CONFIDENT.
I FEEL THAT KIM JONG-UN WANTS TO
DO SOMETHING GREAT FOR HIS
PEOPLE, AND HE HAS THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
AND HE WON'T HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN.
IT'S NEVER GOING TO BE THERE
AGAIN.
>> KIM JONG-UN HAD ARRIVED
EARLIER IN THE DAY TRAVELING
FARTHER THAN HE EVER HAS AS
NORTH KOREA'S LEADER COURTESY OF
CHINA'S NATIONAL AIRLINES.
KIM LATER MEETING WITH THE
SUMMIT HOST SINGAPORE'S PRIME
MINISTER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL MEET WITH
HIM TODAY.
THE RED LINE AT TUESDAY'S TALKS
THE COMPLETE VERIFIABLE
DISMANTINGLING -- DISMANTLING OF
NORTH KOREA'S NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
>> HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE WHETHER
OR NOT THEY ARE SERIOUS?
I SAID MAYBE IN THE FIRST
MINUTE.
YOU KNOW THE WAY THEY SAY YOU
KNOW IF YOU ARE GOING TO LIKE
SOMEBODY IN THE FIRST FIVE
SECONDS, YOU EVER HEAR THAT ONE?
WELL, I THINK THAT VERY QUICKLY
I WILL KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
SOMETHING GOOD IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
>> BACK HOME, CALLS FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO BRING WHATEVER DEAL
HE CUTS WITH KIM TO CONGRESS.
MASSACHUSETTS SENATOR ED MARKEY
WHO NEVER ASKED PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S IRAN DEAL TO BE RATIFIED
SAYS CONGRESS SHOULD HAVE ITS
SAY.
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE WISE FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO COME TO
CONGRESS TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
A RATIFICATION OF ANY AGREEMENT
WHICH DOES TAKE PLACE BETWEEN
THE NORTH KOREANS AND THE UNITED
STATES.
>> BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD
ALREADY PREEMPTED MARKEY SAYING
ON FRIDAY HE WOULD MAKE ANY
AGREEMENT WITH NORTH KOREA A
TREATY, UNLIKE THE IRAN DEAL.
>> I WOULD ONLY DO A DEAL IF I
GET IT THROUGH CONGRESS.
I WOULDN'T DO LIKE OBAMA DID.
>> AS HE ARRIVES IN SINGAPORE
FOR PERHAPS THE MOST IMPORTANT
MEETING OF HIS PRESIDENCY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP LEAVES BEHIND
GRUMBLING ALLIES AT THE G-7,
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP DEPARTED
QUEBEC, CANADA'S PRIME MINISTER
RIPPED HIM UP ONE SIDE AND DOWN
THE OTHER ON TRADE.
>> IT IS KIND OF INSULTING.
AND I HIGHLIGHTED THAT IT WAS
NOT HELPING IN OUR RENEGOTIATION
OF NAFTA.
>> THAT PROMPTED RETALIATION
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO TWEETED
HE HAS INSTRUCTED OUR U.S. REPS
NOT TO ENDORSE THE SUMMIT
COMMUNIQUE AND CRITICIZED
TRUDEAU AS DISHONEST AND WEAK.
CHIEF ECONOMIC ADVISOR LARRY
KUDLOW SAID TRUDEAU STABBED THE
PRESIDENT IN THE BACK, DOUBLE
CROSSED HIM.
>> TRUDEAU DECIDED TO ATTACK THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S THE KEY POINT.
AND YES, YOU KNOW, IF YOU ATTACK
THIS PRESIDENT, HE'S GOING TO
FIGHT BACK.
>> KUDLOW ADDED THERE IS NO ROOM
FOR A SHOW OF WEAKNESS BEFORE
THIS IMPORTANT SUMMIT ON
TUESDAY.
HERE'S THE WAY IT WILL UNFOLD,
THE PRESIDENT'S FIRST MEETING
WILL OCCUR AT 9:00 IN THE
MORNING SINGAPORE TIME.
IT WILL BE A ONE-ON-ONE WITH KIM
JONG-UN, JUST THE TWO LEADERS
PLUS THEIR INTERPRETERS.
AN EXPANDED MEETING WILL HAPPEN
LATER